I don't know why I wrote this jesus take
the wheel hey guys I'm Abby char welcome
to Abby's kitchen and another hilarious
edition of the ridiculous now I've
scoured the internet and compiled all of
your submissions to help you find the
most ridiculous health and wellness
products on the market so this is my
real-time unfiltered uncensored reaction
help you cut through the [ __ ] online
let's do this so first on the ridiculous
is anti-anxiety stickers now these are
brought to us by body vibes they claim
to liberate guilt and fear and help us
transform fear into forgiveness they
also cost 60 bucks a pack now as a kid I
was definitely a proud sandy lion
sticker club member but what the [ __ ]
apparently these little pieces of paper
with adhesive glue on the back contain
396 Hertz in a synergistic combination
of supporting frequencies whatever the
[ __ ] that means if that's not crunchy
enough for you the website goes on to
explain that these stickers are based on
the chakra system to help you detox and
cleanse the inflammation from your body
and mind from stickers now I'm sure
there are some merits of chakra system
it's been practiced in Hinduism and
Buddhism for centuries however I'm not
sure about putting a sticker on my
forehead is going to replace my out of
them
you think I can come down off this very
easily at night you know I'm gonna go
out on a limb here and say skip the $60
stickers and like go take a yoga or
meditation class instead and if you're
still curious go pick up like a dollar
store pack of stickers and go to town
and if you're like me and considering
rejoining the sand Alliance sticker Club
then you can check out the link right
here not an affiliate link but
definitely worth checking out next up on
the ridiculous
per diet slimming mist now forget about
eating well exercise and more
importantly genetics apparently the
secret to long-lasting weight loss is
just some liquid that you've discreetly
spray under your tongue who know okay so
one ball of the stuff contains 22
ingredients including some very common
appetite suppressants like Garcinia
cambogia and Kodiak captain
sounds like a strippers name right
welcome to the stage Garcinia cambogia
and the booty out cactus butt let's dive
into them a little bit further based on
a systematic review garcinia is being
shown to maybe induce weight loss
however like all weight loss the results
have been shown to be very short-term
small and not even necessarily
clinically significant awesome ask for
hoodia movie uh one famous study
actually found it had no effect on
calorie intake and weight loss but in
fact had some really serious side
effects like nausea and vomiting awesome
also the fact that this diet mist is so
blatantly marketed towards women is
making my blood boil twenty-five dollars
for a patriarchal balm spray next so
next up on the ridiculous is the
weirdest new fitness trend crawling
apparently this is like the new planking
of the fitness world and even if I can
give it like the benefit of the doubt
and make the assumption that sure it
might be a useful core strengthening
exercise especially based on research
that firefighters have found that
crawling may be beneficial to their
training I just can't get behind the
whoo of the trend and the fact that a
workshop cost $300 to crawl $300 $300
I'm sorry if you didn't catch that
that's $300 to crawl so apparently when
we crawl we go back to our roots of
being a baby which helps us to reset our
body and undo any physical damage
I call them [ __ ] on that one now
what I say that crawling like exercises
like bird dog are good for your core
strength absolutely but you're not gonna
turn back the hands of time pretending
that you're a toddler what is next
thousand dollar tummy time sessions led
by Quinnie Paltrow's kids by next so
next on the ridiculous
is the bite ox hangover patch yay more
stickers so apparently if you apply this
five-dollar patch 45 minutes before you
go to the bar and then keep it on for
eight hours after it's been shown to
help restore your body and rid yourself
of the dreaded hangover can you like
imagine for a hot minute how awkward it
would be trying to explain to your
drunken hookup about the weird sticky on
your arm if that does not result in a
Houdini move you've either got a real
gem or a really desperate one I'm not
sure well let's talk about some science
here folks so the skin patch is packed
with vitamins minerals and antioxidants
which might sound really promising
however research has found that none of
these actually help prevent or reduce a
hangover so I've done a video on the
perfect hangover cure but the reality is
no food pill or sticker is going to cure
it the only thing that's gonna help you
is sleep hydration and maybe a time
machine to help erase those last two
tequila shots actually I'm pretty sure
going with Paltrow selling those these
days this just seems like another bad
life decision what makes it 2:00 in the
morning after last call save the money
and use it to goober home maybe one or
two shots early and last but definitely
not least the new foreskin facial I have
a lot of questions the new foreskin
facial oh hell no we are at this point
in our society folks in I don't know
what to say about it but apparently
apparently people are marketing a serum
made from the liquidized
foreskins of circumcised South Korean
babies
the treatment cost 500 pounds with a 200
waiting list
thanks to celebrities like Kate
Beckinsale Cate Blanchett and Sandra
Bullock I have a lot of questions my
first question is what kind of sick
thought this up and my second question
is why are the South Koreans what's so
special about their dick skin I got a
thing bixton whoa okay
is there a better word for them dick
skin these are my questions these are my
legitimate questions dick skin you call
it a dick skin okay I will say diskens
for skins how's that yeah okay well
we'll talk about okay second question
why is it just South Korean babies I
mean what's wrong with Canadians
foreskins dick skins third did the
babies and/or parents consent to this is
there like a waiver you have to sign
these donate it do they get money up
from their dick skins what is happening
I mean my son was circumcised and I do
not remember ever consenting to
something like this I think I would
remember this so what kind of anti-aging
properties does this foreskin facial
possess well apparently the foreskin
helps generate collagen and elastin
which makes your skin glow like a baby's
dick this is a pretty good example of
white celebrity-driven privilege taken
to a disturbing level and I'm taking a
hard pass at this well guys that is it
for this edition of the ridiculous
if you loved this video be sure to give
it the thumbs up subscribe to the
channel and definitely leave me a
comment below some of the most
ridiculous health and wellness products
that you've seen out there on the market
I would love to review them in an
upcoming video thanks so much guys see
you next time bye
[Music]